all righty let's jump on the roads check
the drive any problems nate uh here in
town absolutely none i mean it is going
to get crowded around the shopping malls
and the folks who are already camped out
for black friday deals but the freeways
are rolling on in excellent shape
surface treats as well however
leaving las vegas heading north on the
15 to mesquite you are going to be
stopped because of a fatal auto
pedestrian crash at mile marker 102. so
mile marker 93 is the exit that gets you
down to logandale and overton in the
moapa valley mesquite is actually at
mile mark 120 so in between the
logandale exit and mesquite that's where
you're going to be stopped i got a nice
text message from trooper wellman of the
nevada state police nowhere for folks to
turn around some are making u-turns
across the center median around mile
marker 100 but all you're doing there is
just coming back south and headed for
the las vegas area where else you may
want to stop to pull over but for now
you are not going to be going through
northbound on the i-15
through the mesquite area because of
this fatal auto pedestrian crash the
town of mesquite itself is pretty sleepy
right now